[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nick fridell covers
the warriors for espn.com and he joins
us now what are the early reports nick
dan the warriors don't feel great about
everything the fear is that it's an
achilles injury
but i can tell you even a few hours ago
they were still holding out hope that it
wasn't
as severe initially as it appeared to be
so while they're bracing for the worst
certainly there is still some optimism
and myers hinted at that
during his conference call he said look
it doesn't look great but
we're just hoping for the best and we'll
see what happens when the tests come
how was he progressing from his knee
surgery from a year ago
he looked great by all accounts steve
kerr bob myers they've all said the same
thing in recent weeks
they said that this guy is looking like
the player that we had seen before now
it's worth noting then that
when the warriors had their team bubble
back in late september
thompson still wasn't cleared for
scrimmages the warriors were being very
cautious because remember at that point
it was still the nba season could start
in january february nobody really knew
for sure but he
started to ramp it up the last few weeks
they had seen him they said he looked
like the old clay
and it was just a gut punch for
everybody within that organization
did their draft strategy change at all
or come close to changing at all last
night because of this injury
not one bit wiseman was the guy that
they targeted all along
he was the number one pick on their
board
they knew that he would fill an
immediate hole
in the middle being able to defend
pairing him with draymond being able to
learn from draymond every day
they liked him all along and myers said
flatly
it didn't change one thing because if
wiseman was there
we were going to take him it's obviously
a big loss to
lose klay thompson and i don't know
who fills that void can anybody fill
that void do they change
different you know they play differently
the style this year
with golden state i think it's too
ingrained i don't think anything can
change from a system standpoint and then
certainly
nobody's filling clay's role he did so
many things for them
and we we know about the jumpers but
defensively
steve kerr loved the fact that you could
just throw him out there on the floor
and he would take care of whoever the
best
wing defender was on the other team so
he trusted him
immensely but i'd say on top of
who fills the wing rolls and that's
where the warriors were short already
it was kind of only clay and andrew
wiggins the
the part that's really hurting
internally right now
is the emotional side because this is a
guy
even with steph and draymond and kd when
he was there
clay was the most beloved clay was the
guy that
really set the tone behind the scenes
and and curtis talked about it a lot
over the years clay is an egoless player
he can just kind of fit in
and do whatever they needed and to see
that he may be
down again for a while is really hurting
everybody on that team right now yeah
i remember steve kerr telling me years
ago he just said clay
is uh there's no maintenance to it like
i don't have to worry about
anything it's not touches or being a
star
or points or anything he said he just he
is maintenance free
and that's rare it's very rare and he
doesn't want any part of the spotlight
and then in all the years i've covered
the league i i certainly have never
seen anybody like clay because he he
goes and hits all these shots and
is a really solid defender when he wants
to be and then he just kind of goes home
and he's content just kind of hanging
out with his dog and doing his own thing
he doesn't like talking to the media
although he's one of the best quotes on
the team and
that resonates for a lot of people and
it's not to say that
they don't love steph and draymond in
their own way because they absolutely do
it's just that clay marches to his own
beat and it's
so different than most stars in the
league and that's what made him unique
so on top of the fact that
consistently he was out there game after
game
putting in the work and putting up the
numbers
it was the tone he set with all the
other star power on that roster that
that kerr and myers love so much you
have an owner who
seems like he's pretty aggressive to get
fans in the stands this upcoming season
what is the game plan he's going to try
the lake of his as much as he can to get
people in there
then the reality though is it's going to
be tough because san francisco is
is starting to shut uh more again
after a recent surge in inktober cases
so
lacup is still gonna to push the
envelope the warriors are behind him
he's gonna put his
own money in to do it it's just gonna be
so difficult and and i can just tell you
personally i i was living 10 minutes
away from the arena
to see that thing empty day after day
is is a crusher uh for for that team
and for ownership because that was
supposed to be the cash towel of cash
cows
and it's not to say it still can't be
over time
but it's empty it was supposed to be
filled
every day with concerts and other events
all the time on top of all the games and
and now
to see that the way it is that's why
you're seeing from wake up and from the
warriors this push so hard to get
some people back in there and start to
get the revenue streams going again
is there a time frame for this mri today
with klay thompson
i would expect the news in the next
couple hours i i
i think everybody was expecting it to be
in the morning and you mentioned kerr
and some of the trainers are headed down
there and
it may be there in the moment but i
would expect
something here very soon nick thanks for
joining us we appreciate your time
dan i've listened to you my whole life i
i really appreciate you guys having me
thank you nick that's uh nick friedel he
covers the warriors for espn.com